RECORD.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
"ANGLE"."
FOR MONTHS NOW, THE MEDIA, AND
FRANKLY, MOST DEMOCRATS, HAVE
BEEN ACTING AS THOUGH
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DIRECTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERY CASE OF
COVID-19 IN THE U.S.
NOW, BACK IN
MARTH, "HANNITY,"
"
LIKE MANY, WERE DISMAYED THE CD
SEED IS INITIALLY MISHANDLED
TESTING.
TODAY, WE LEAVE THE WORLD AND
>> WE DO MORE TESTING THAN
ANYBODY IN THE WORLD, IF YOU
LOOK AT INDIA, ABOUT 11 MILLION,
61 MILLION.
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS INCREDIBLE
WITH THE TESTING, AND WE WILL
CONTINUE, BUT WE WANT TO TEST
VERY SPECIFICALLY THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN MOST DANGER, MOST IN
NEED.
>> Laura: EXCELLENT ANSWER,
AND YET, THE CONSTANT BELITTLING
OF THE ADMINISTRATION’S EFFORT
IS DEEPLY UNFAIR, AND IT’S
ALMOST ENTIRELY POLITICAL.
TONIGHT, I THINK THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT, THIS "ANGLE" TONIGHT,
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO SET THIS
RECORD STRAIGHT.
WE START WITH THE BIGGEST LIES
PEDDLED BY THE LEFT.
FIRST, THAT THE PRESIDENT
DOESN’T TAKE THE PANDEMIC
SERIOUSLY.
>> DON’T FORGET, LET’S NOT
FORGET THAT HE DOWNPLAYED THIS
VIRUS FOR MONTHS.
>> WHAT HAS HAPPENED HERE IS
THAT DONALD TRUMP HAS DOWNPLAYED
THIS VIRUS SINCE THE BEGINNING.
>> THIS MAN IS DETERMINED TO
KEEP DOWN HIS GOLF HANDICAP, NOT
THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT ARE
MAKING US SICK.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID THE VIRUS
IS A HOAX.
>> Laura: NOW, WHILE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE HYPERVENTILATING
OVER THE BOGUS IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS AND THE MEDIA WAS
BEMOANING ANTI-CHINA BIAS AND
THE REACTION INITIALLY TO THE
VIRUS, THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
CREATED A COVID TASK FORCE ON
JANUARY 29TH.
TWO DAYS LATER, THE PRESIDENT
DECLARED A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY, AND HE ORDERED ANY
U.S. CITIZENS RETURNING FROM
CHINA TO QUARANTINE FOR 14 DAYS.
ON FEBRUARY 2ND, TRUMPS TRAVEL
BAN FROM CHINA WENT INTO EFFECT.
THAN THE PRESIDENT WENT ON TO
BAN TRAVEL FROM EUROPE IN MARCH,
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE UNHAPPY
WITH THAT.
BUT BOTH OF THOSE ACTIONS HAVE
BEEN APPLAUDED BY THE LEFT’S
BIGGEST HERO.
>> WERE YOU INVOLVED IN WORKING
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP ON DECIDING
TO BAN FLIGHTS FROM CHINA?
>> YES I WAS.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT DECISION
SAVE LIVES?
>> YES, I DO.
>> WHEN WE ULTIMATELY SAW
SPREADING IN EUROPE AND THE
PRESIDENT RECOMMENDED WE EXTEND
THAT TO EUROPE, DO YOU THINK
THAT DECISION SAVED LIVES?
>> YES, I DO.
>> Laura: BINGO.
NOW, SECOND LIE, THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE DIDN’T DO ENOUGH TO
ALLEVIATE THE MEDICAL SUPPLY
SHORTAGE.
>> THE COUNTRY IS FACING YET
ANOTHER DANGEROUS SHORTAGE OF
PPE AND MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
SUPPLIES.
>> RIGHT NOW, THIS COUNTRY
CANNOT MEET CORONAVIRUS WITHOUT
MORE PPE.
WE HAD A SHORTAGE.
>> WE HAVE TO RESET, SURGING
CASES, LONG LINES FOR TESTS, NOT
ENOUGH PPE COMMENTS BEFORE DOING
EXACTLY WHAT HE DID IN MARCH AND
APRIL WHICH WAS TO MINIMIZE --
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT
INVOKED THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION
ACT BACK IN MARCH.
GIVING HIM CONTROL OVER PRIVATE
BUSINESS AND THE ECONOMY, THE
PRESIDENT WISELY USE THE ACT
ONLY WHEN BUSINESSES DIDN’T
VOLUNTARILY DEVOTE ASSEMBLY
LINES TO PRODUCING PPE,
VENTILATORS, OTHER MUCH-NEEDED
SUPPLIES.
SO, IF ANDREW CUOMO PROJECTED --
REMEMBER, THEY NEED AS MANY AS,
WHAT, 30,000 OR 40,000 BEDS?
WE TOLD YOU THAT FIGURE WAS
ABSURD, BUT THE WHITE HOUSE
KICKED INTO HIGH GEAR, ANYWAY.
THERE WAS A MASS MOBILIZATION OF
RESOURCES, INCLUDING SETTING UP
FIELD HOSPITALS IN NEW YORK AND
USING NAVY SHIPS THAT ENDED UP,
OF COURSE, BEING HARDLY
UTILIZED.
BUT IT WAS ALL DONE TO ENSURE
THAT THE TRI-STATE AREA’S
HOSPITAL SYSTEM DIDN’T
ULTIMATELY COLLAPSE.
AND GUESS WHAT?
IT DIDN’T.
AND WHEN WE WERE THREE MONTHS
OUT FROM A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, ANDREW CUOMO REGULARLY
ACKNOWLEDGED THE BILLIONS IN
HELP.
>> THE PRESIDENT BROUGHT IN THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS.
THEY BUILT 2500 BEDS AT JAVITS.
THESE WERE JUST EXTRAORDINARY
EFFORTS AND ACTS OF MOBILIZATION
MOBILIZATION.
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
STEPPED UP AND WAS A GREAT
PARTNER, AND I’M THE FIRST WANT
TO SAY IT.
WE NEEDED HELP, AND THEY WERE
THERE.
>> Laura: YESTERDAY, HE WAS
TRASHING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
NICE GOING.
THIS WHOPPER, SPEAKING OF
NEW YORK, THAT NEW YORK IS
SOMEHOW THE GOLD STANDARD FOR
THE REST OF AMERICA.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN FLATLINED FOR
THE LAST FOUR WEEKS.
THAT’S AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT CAN BE
DONE.
>> GOVERNOR CUOMO, IN
PARTICULAR, DID AT THE RIGHT WAY
FROM MARCH ON.
>> FIRM LANGUAGE, LIFE-SAVING
MANDATES BY OUR LEADERS.
HE CLEARLY WAS LISTENING TO HIS
HEALTH ADVISORS.
>> Laura: UNLIKE THEM LIBERAL
MEDIA, NUMBERS DON’T LIE.
WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT FLORIDA,
ARIZONA, AND TEXAS NOT FOLLOWING
IN CUOMO’S FOOTSTEPS, BUT LOOK
AT THIS CHART.
THE DEATH RATE PER 100,000 IN
NEW YORK IS OVER THREE TIMES THE
DEATH RATE IN ARIZONA.
NEARLY FIVE TIMES THE DEATH RATE
IN FLORIDA, AND OVER SIX TIMES
AT THE DEATH RATE IN TEXAS.
NO WONDER NEW YORK’S TOP HEALTH
OFFICIAL RESIGNED TODAY.
NOW, WHEN THE MEDIA HARPS ON OUR
COVID DEATH NUMBERS, NATIONAL
NUMBERS, THEY FAIL TO MENTION
THE STATES WITH THE HIGHEST
NUMBERS.
>> NEW YORK HAD A VERY TOUGH
TIME, AS YOU KNOW, NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, THAT AREA, BUT WHEN
YOU TAKE THAT OUTCOME OF THE
NUMBERS ARE THE LOWEST.
>> Laura: NOW, THE PRESIDENT
LEFT NEW YORK, BUT THE NOTION
THAT THESE STATES SHOULD BE
TAKING ADVICE FROM
GOVERNOR CUOMO -- OR ANYONE,
FRANKLY, WHO PRESIDED OVER THE
DISASTER IN THE EMPIRE STATE --
IS JUST ABSURD.
FOR FLY, THE LEFT FALSELY BLAMES
TRUMP FOR THE ECONOMY TANKING
LAST QUARTER.
>> MISHANDLING OF THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC IS NOT GOOD
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
THAT IS BAD NEWS FOR THE
ECONOMY.
>> JUST DECIMATED OUR ECONOMY.
>> WITH OUR ECONOMY’S WORST DROP
EVER.
OKAY?
32.9%.
>> Laura: THE LAST CLAIM YOU
HEARD ABOUT U.S. GDP SHRINKING
32.9% IS A SECOND QUARTER OF
THIS YEAR IS AN INSANELY
MISLEADING, AND WHILE IT’S
TECHNICALLY NH TRUE, THE FIGURE
REPRESENTS AN ANNUAL NUMBER,
IN OTHER WORDS, THE AMOUNT OF
THE DECLINE THAT WOULD TAKE
PLACE OVER A YEAR IF TRENDS FROM
THE SECOND QUARTER CONTINUED.
NOW, THAT WOULD ONLY HAPPEN IF
WE FOLLOWED BIDEN’S
RECOMMENDATIONS TO SHUT DOWN THE
ECONOMY AND KEEP KIDS OUT OF
SCHOOL, THOUGHTS, PARENTS OUT OF
WORK.
ON A NONANNUALIZED BASIS, THE
DECLINE FROM Q1 TO Q2, IT’S
STILL A STAGGERING LOSS, DON’T
GET ME WRONG, BUT ONE THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY QUICKLY RECOVER
FROM IF TRUMP IS ABLE TO
CONTINUE WITH HIS PRO-FREEDOM
AGENDA.
NOW, OF COURSE, ONCE YOU DIG
INTO THE NUMBERS, IT’S EASY TO
SEE WHICH STATES ARE HOLDING
BACK A FULL-FLEDGED RECOVERY.
THE BLUE ONES!
IN NEVADA AND HAWAII HAVE AN
EXCUSE BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEMS
RESULTING FROM TOURISM, BUT WHY
ARE ALL OF THESE OTHER STATES ON
THIS LIST STILL DOING SO POORLY?
BECAUSE THEY FAILED TO TAKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S ADVICE, AND
RATHER THAN TRUSTING THEIR
PEOPLE, THEY IMPOSED DRASTIC
LOCKDOWN MEASURES THAT HAD
CATASTROPHIC ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES WHILE DOING VERY
LITTLE TO STOP THE VIRUS.
IT’S ALSO WORTH REMEMBERING
WHERE THIS VIRUS CAME FROM:
CHINA.
WHY AREN’T DEMOCRATS CLAIMING TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
UNLEASHING THIS FLAG ON THE
WORLD AFTER, OF COURSE, THEY
INITIALLY TRIED TO COVER IT UP.
FOR THAT MATTER, WHY ARE
DEMOCRATS PUSHING FOR MORE
FUNDING TO THE W.H.O., WHICH
AIDED AND ABETTED CHINA’S LIES.
FOR FLY, DESPITE THE DISMAL
PERFORMANCE OF LOCKDOWN-LOVING
BLUE STATES, DEMOCRATS STILL
COMPLAIN THAT WE DIDN’T FOLLOW
YOUR UPS AND LEAD IN HANDLING
COVID.
>> WE DID NOT WAIT TO CRUSH THE
CURVE IN EUROPE, THEY DID THE EX
OPPOSITE.
>> COMPARED TO EUROPE, WE HAVE
TO GET OUR VIRUS UNDER CONTROL
LIKE THEY DID BEFORE WE CAN
START REOPENING SCHOOLS.
>> THIS APPEARS, THE NUMBER OF
NEW, DAILY CORONAVIRUS CASES IN
THE UNITED STATES WITH THOSE IN
IT SHOWS JUST HOW MUCH WORSE THE
OUTBREAK HAS BEEN IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> AND LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS,
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THE
U.S. IS AN ENORMOUS COUNTRY WITH
ABOUT 330 MILLION PEOPLE.
BUT WHEN YOU ADD THE POPULATIONS
OF GERMANY, BRITAIN, FRANCE,
ITALY, SPAIN, AND BELGIUM, THEY,
TOGETHER, HAVE ALMOST
336 MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT’S ROUGHLY EQUAL TO OUR
POPULATION.
SO, FIRST OFF, ON TESTING, WE
PERFORMED BETTER THAN THOSE
EUROPEAN WESTERN COUNTRIES.
THEY’VE DONE 32.8 MILLION TESTS
FOR COVID-19, WE’VE DONE
59.9 MILLION.
SINCE WE’VE PERFORMED SO MANY
MORE TESTS, WE CAN’T REALLY DO
AN APPLES-TO-APPLES COMPARISON
ON CONFIRMED COVID CASE NUMBERS.
BUT, OF COURSE, WE CAN LOOK AT
DEATH’S.
WE HAVE SUFFERED.
WE SUFFERED 158,000 DEATHS, IT’S
A TERRIFIC TRAGEDY, BUT THE
SIX EUROPEAN COUNTRIES VINE HAVE
SUFFERED ROUGHLY 159,000 DEATHS.
AN EQUAL HORRIFIC TRAGEDY.
LIKEWISE, OR DEATH RATES ARE
LOWER THAN MANY OF OUR EUROPEAN
COUNTERPARTS.
BELGIUM, THE U.K., SPAIN, ITALY,
HAVE SEEN WAY WORSE DEATH RATES
THAN WE HAVE.
FRANCE IS ONLY DOING SLIGHTLY
BETTER THAN WE ARE IN TERMS OF
DEATHS, AS WELL.
AND WHAT WE ALSO HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE AS THE U.S., OF
COURSE, AS I SAID, A MASSIVE
COUNTRY.
IF YOU BREAK IT DOWN BY STATES,
IT’S CLEAR THE DEMOCRAT STATES
ARE THE REASON THAT THE DEATH
RATES ARE SO HIGH, IT JUST
HAPPENS TO WORK OUT THAT WAY,
RIGHT?
WE CAN ALSO SAY THAT OUR ECONOMY
HAS DONE SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER
THAN EUROPE’S.
REMEMBER THAT THE U.S. ECONOMY
FELL BY 9.5% ON A QUARTERLY
BASIS.
THE EUROZONE, THAT IS THE
ECONOMY OF ALL OF THE NATIONS
THAT USE THE EURO, FELL BY
12.1%.
EVEN GERMANY SUFFERED A DECLINE
OF 10.1%.
BUT AREN’T THE EUROPEANS GOING
TO DO BETTER THAN US GOING
FORWARD?
WELL, THAT’S NOT WHAT INVESTORS
THINK.
LET’S LOOK AT HOW THE KEY STOCK
INDEX INDICES HAVE DONE SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEARS, IN
OTHER WORDS, INVESTORS ARE NOT
BETTING THAT WESTERN EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES ARE MORE VALUABLE THAN
THEIR AMERICAN COUNTERPARTS.
IF ANYTHING, THEIR BETS ARE ALL
THE OTHER WAY.
SO, WE’VE PERFORMED 17 MILLION
MORE TESTS THAN OUR COUNTERPARTS
IN WESTERN EUROPE, WE HAVE
ROUGHLY THE SAME NUMBER OF
DEATHS.
OUR ECONOMY, THOUGH, IS MUCH
STRONGER.
INVESTORS HAVE MORE CONFIDENCE
IN OUR OUTLOOK GOING FORWARD.
BUT WHILE THESE FIGURES CLEARLY
SHOW THAT THE U.S. IS DOING VERY
WELL BY COMPARISON TO OUR ALLIES
IN EUROPE, THEY DON’T GIVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ENOUGH CREDIT.
BECAUSE THE U.S. FIGURES ARE
DISTORTED BY THE POOR
PERFORMANCE OF MANY OF THE BLUE
STATE GOVERNORS.
HERE ARE THE FACTS.
THE U.S. AS A WHOLE HAS SUFFERED
48 DEATHS PER 100,000 FROM
COVID-19.
BUT SEVEN STATES HAVE SUFFERED
DEATHS AT A RATE HIGHER THAN
EVEN SPAIN DID.
HERE YOU SEE THE CATASTROPHIC
RESULT OF POOR LOCAL GOVERNANCE,
ESPECIALLY IN AND AROUND
NEW YORK CITY.
IN FACT, NEW YORK’S DEATH RATE
WAS TWO WENT ON HALF TIMES WORSE
THAN SPAIN.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE SHOULD ALL
BE GRATEFUL THAT DURING THIS
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS INSULATED
MOST OF THE COUNTRY FROM THE
DISASTROUS TOP-DOWN POLICIES AND
LOCKDOWNS AND LOOTING, FRANKLY,
THAT DEMOCRATS SEEM TO WANT TO
LOOK THE OTHER WAY ON.
THANK GOODNESS.
AND THAT’S THE "ANGLE."
AND PART TWO, TOMORROW NIGHT, WE
ARE GOING TO JOURNEY THROUGH THE
CRISIS AS IT COULD HAVE UNFOLDED